[Music]
Margeaux director David Ayer surprised
you on the set I think the first day
with a razor what was that all about
he cut a chunk out of my eyebrow okay
honestly I I didn't feel too hard done
by because he'd cut off Karen all the
Karen's hair actually I had had about to
hear to repeat a pair that he just cut
off my hair as well but what is this
fixation with me first of all lovely why
did he need to take out a piece of your
eyebrows I don't know it kind of came
out of a blue and look like autumn I
also used to be a barber in the Navy I
mean that's the first thing so there's
no reason for it right it sounds like an
HR problem and you shaved parts of your
body a month old yes that's what I was
told it's right here in the research you
want me to show the photographs I mean
what do you want
I'll do what I got to do all the weight
oddly it's I I did two films in a row
where I either waxed or shaved my entire
body and my eyebrows and I wore lipstick
which is a party yeah two in a row on
that one I don't know if you like the
way you leaned in to be like you
understand don't you go I understand
completely
I've been taught to have to call that
one a pattern I'm entirely hairless
you